I do know that the U.S wants control of  Ukraine Western forces NATO because  Russia controls a large percentage  percentage of natural gas flowing into  Europe which means that the economy of  Europe is staggered by Russia so the U.S  basically wants to take control of  Ukraine control the valves of natural  gas into Europe and then put the  pressure back on Russia Russia refuses  War happens  so I suppose  um you can argue NATO should not have  been expanding the way it was and we'd  avoid war and high gas prices is better  than War I think that's a part of it but  I think but we wouldn't have high gas  prices we would have lower gas prices if  we had just uh better relations with  other countries and more free trade in  the market Russia was charging a lot and  so Western forces tried to build a  pipeline through Syria through turkey  into Europe to compete with Russia but  Syria wouldn't allow it surprise  surprise Syria destabilizes how  fortunate